My name is Ben Abbott.
I've been making blades since
I was about 13 years old.
I was born in
Worcester, England.
When I saw all the cool
armor, and weapons, and stuff,
I just decided to start
making it for myself.
My name's Tom McGinnis.
I'm 73 years old, and
I love knife making.
I made my first knife in 1958.
I'm an old duck, but
I'm gonna hang tough.
WIL WILLIS: Ben,
Tom, congratulations.
You've made it to the
"Forged in Fire" final.
And now we're sending
you back to your home
forges to recreate an
iconic weapon from history,
the khanda .
The khanda is a sword
that gained popularity
in medieval India
during the Gupta
period between 320 and 550 AD.
The word khanda is derived from
the Sanskrit word [sanskrit],,
meaning to break,
divide, cut, or destroy.
It's wide, thick,
straight blade was
not only used for thrusting,
but also as a hacking weapon.
When a Rajput warrior was
surrounded by the enemy,
he would pull out the
khanda and fight to the end
while swinging the
blade with both hands,
taking down as many
enemies as he could
in an honorable last stand.
It has to be an
authentic, working replica
of that deadly weapon.
The mystery
weapon is a khanda.
I think it's a
real doable blade.
I believe I can produce one.
Bladesmiths, good luck.
BEN: So it's day one.
My strategy going into
building this blade
is that I'm going to make
a couple of test blades.
The most crucial part of this
build is whatever I have to do
to get it through the testing.
I can make the prettiest
thing in the world.
If it snaps in two,
I'm going to lose.
I'm going to quench the sword.
[cackling]
The quench went really well.
Very excited about that.
Now I have to dive
into the handle.
The handle is nothing like
I've ever seen before.
I lost 10 hours
working on this sword.
Got to just finish
grinding the blade.
I wrap the handle in leather.
It'll bulk out the handle
and make it more comfortable
so that it really kind
of holds your hand snugly
and feels really good.
Holy cow.
What a long journey.
TOM: It feels good
to be back home
where I have my own equipment.
Today I'm going to try and
get the shapes of the guard
and get the blade ground.
The blade we had
to make is designed
for fighting double handed,
and it had a big D guard on it,
and I've never done that.
It's quite an awesome blade.
I got the blade ground.
Seems to be going real good,
and I'm going to try and get
the handle all put together.
I'm going to ask God to
help me with this one.
God answered my prayer.
It's pretty straight if
it will just cool down.
Now, I know this
blade's going to cut.
It's ready for the judges.
Ben is gonna contend
with a tough old dog.
Tom, Ben, welcome
back to the forge.
We will now be putting
each of your weapons
through three tests.
Doug?
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
To test the lethality and
function of your weapon,
I will take your weapon and
deliver three vertical chops
and then a slice.
Ben, you're up.
You ready?
I guess so.
Let's do this.
BEN: I'm a little bit nervous.
There's a lot of bones in there.
But this sword is made to
cut, so let's see it cut.
[music playing]
Well, Ben, the damage
that your blade did cut
about six inches deep into
both shoulders and right
through the spine.
On the horizontal
slice, it pretty much
cut all the way through.
It's got a good feel.
This, sir, will kill.
Thank you.
Tom, it's your turn.
You ready?
I'm ready.
I don't like losing at all.
I like to win.
In the kill test, I
think it's doable.
I really do.
[music playing]
DOUG: Tom, you definitely
cut in about six inches
deep on the shoulders
and about eight inches
into the spinal column.
You cut halfway through
into the carcass.
Also feels good in balance
with a downward vertical slice.
There was a slight bend that's
happening to your blade,
but it will kill.
Bladesmiths, this is
the sharpness test.
I will slash across
these bungee cords.
If your blade is sharp, it
should cut all the way through.
If not, it may just push
it aside or bounce off.
Ben, you're up.
Are you ready?
Sure.
At this point, I'm nervous.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm going
to cut through all of them,
or if I'm going to bounce off.
I have no idea.
[bleep]
Well, Ben, your
sword started to cut.
It cut a little bit, but
it did not cut through.
It feels good on the slice.
The handle is very
comfortable in the hand.
Once again, it
didn't cut through,
so it brings into
question the sharpness.
Tom, it's your turn.
You ready?
I'm ready.
DOUG: Let's do this.
TOM: I really feel comfortable
going into the test,
and I know this
blade's going to cut.
I'm ready.
Oh.
DOUG: Well, Tom, it
did cut a little bit
into the bungee cord.
But then--
- Yeah.
--as you can see, the
transference of energy went
all the way back to the blade.
It wasn't sharp
enough to cut through,
and it bent your
blade, which brings
to question the heat treatment
you did on your blade.
Cut around corners now.
[laughter]
It'll cut around
corners this time, right?
But in this particular
case, it will not cut, sir.
When you don't have your
hardening and tampering right
on a blade, you
don't have anything.
Gentlemen, both
of your weapons
failed in the sharpness test.
Historically in
battle, blades bent.
Tom, we'd like to give
you the opportunity
to straighten your
blade so that you
can continue with this fight.
However, we will be taking
that bend into consideration
when it comes to final judging.
I understand.
I should have left thicker,
but I'm not a quitter.
I'm going to fight to the end.
OK, Tom, you've
straightened your blade.
We can continue with testing.
Gentlemen, this is
the strength test.
I'm going to take five chops
into these copper pipes
and see how far
through we can split.
Ben, are you ready?
Not at all.
Yes.
The last thing I would bring
to a plumbing job is a sword.
So I'm just nervous that
the blade will break,
just snap in two.
[music playing]
JUDGE: Wow.
Ben, it's still one
piece, but barely.
And the dimensions of your guard
here on my hand are perfect.
Your blade, it's
held up beautifully.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
So, Tom, your turn.
OK.
JUDGE: All right.
TOM: I'm really nervous
about the pipe cut.
I should have spent
more time on my blade,
because that's what
counts in the end.
Now, Tom, we do have
that bend in your blade,
and we know that there's at
least a soft section in there.
Yeah.
So as I'm cutting, if I feel
that there's a point where it's
unsafe, I'm just gonna stop.
All right?
OK.
[music playing]
So, Tom, what happened is
we lost a piece of the guard
right there.
Yeah.
JUDGE: With the broken
guard and the bend earlier,
I feel it's unsafe to continue.
All right, thank you, Tom.
TOM: I'm disappointed.
I know I can do better, but
that's what happens when
you don't use your time right.
Gentlemen, in just
five days you've
both done an amazing amount
of work on your khandas.
But in this arena, there can
only be one "Forged in Fire"
champion.
Ben, you are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Tom, unfortunately your
weapon did not make the cut.
Tom, as I said before, your
attention to detail is spot on.
It's just that heat-treat
problem with that blade
bending the way it did.
That's why we have
to let you go.
Tom, please
surrender your weapon.
TOM: Well, I got to meet
some real nice craftsmen.
And I learned.
Don't let your
age slow you down.
You don't know how long you got.
Ben, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
Thank you.
Most people get
guard sizes all wrong,
and the khanda has a
deceptively small guard.
You just hit it out of the park.
Thank you.
It feels amazing to be the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
It's a wonderful validation of
a long time of knife making.
And I made new friends.
I made 10 grand.
What more could you ask for?